[Musique]
riposte contre un symbole
en france aussi un restaurant mcdonald's
a été pris pour cible c'était
aujourd'hui à millau dans l'aveyron les
agriculteurs français voulaient ainsi
dénoncer des sanctions commerciales
américaines contre plusieurs de nos
produits dans le roquefort originaire
précisément de cette région car didier
la cible un restaurant en construction
de la chaîne mcdonald's
plusieurs dizaines de personnes
essentiellement des producteurs de lait
de brebis ont saccagé une santé les
manifestants proches de la confédération
paysanne entendait ainsi répondre à la
diffusion américaine qui impose 100 % de
droits de douane sur le fromage de
roquefort en rétorsion douanières qui
ont fait suite à l'interdiction
européenne d'importation de boeuf aux
hormones américain
les manifestants auraient détruit 59 ans
du chantier sans que les forces de
l'ordre interviennent ils ont emporté
symboliquement des matériaux de
construction dans la tente d'une levée
des sanctions américaines
aujourd'hui moi les problèmes
communautaires et internationaux nouveau
commerce ça me dépasse complètement
moi je suis un chef d'entreprise local
ici qui va recruter 35 personnes oui et
réfectoires et en bas et qui fait
travailler aucune entreprise locale pour
qu'on soit 100 mag d'or
les paysans ne sont pas les seuls dans
le département de l'aveyron à s'en
prendre aux symboles de l'industrie
agroalimentaire d'outre-atlantique
également soul de protestation contre
les sanctions douanières américaines
trois cafetiers de rodez pour refuse
désormais de servir du coca cola
[Musique]